you know i was thinking i need a new
game of thrones in my life you know that
ending was freaking bad sorry i almost
used a swear word what's that new
fantasy show coming out uh what is it
the
the wheel of dune time uh the time of
dune yeah i need to get into that i
should read it right i should read it
okay where did you put that stinking
thing this is heavier than you were when
you were born
that's concerning this already reminds
me exactly of gone girl
how there's girl you'd say i'm like a
moraine figure in your life right i'm
calm i'm wise
i'm calm i'm wise yes just like moraine
oh this just got good you know aguain
and rand sort of have like this ross and
rachel thing going on
i hate ross and rachel lan would be the
perfect boyfriend for you you know he's
tough he's a poet
he's equally scared of commitment really
no you should just give joshua a second
chance that's all i'm saying
oh oh okay shut the [ __ ] up did they no
i just finished and i need a sequel um
it's like 4am
there's a sequel right tell me there's a
sequel yeah there are like 13 other
sequels
i'm canceling our vacation to europe mom
i need to read